what we want to see from the chancellor
on wednesday
is an absolute determination to protect
jobs
and businesses in the uk and to secure
our recovery
that must be at the front of the
chancellor's mind
not any party political considerations
about what's best
for the conservative party at the next
general election but he needs to focus
on what's right for our country right
now to secure that recovery
there are lots of reports that rishi
sedak is going to be increasing
corporation tax and something that you
said that you won't support
why is it then that you don't want to
see a rise in corporation tax now but in
2019 you stood as a shadow treasury
minister on a manifesto calling for
higher corporation tax
well like over the last 10 years the
conservatives have pulled our country
further and further away
from the mainstream on corporation tax
and actually that's not
resulted in additional investment we've
seen investment actually
being rised at a lower level in the uk
compared to many other
countries what the conservatives are
doing now though isn't setting out that
long-term plan to rebalance
our tax system in fact they're kicking
the can down the road when it comes to
business rates reform
what they seem to be focused on doing
particularly the chancellor
is trying to get any tax changes out of
the way
quickly get them out of the way so that
they can then have a general election
when they can cut taxes now instead they
should be focused
all of the time on building jobs and
businesses in our country so we can
secure
that economic recovery you know the uk's
had the worst
economic crisis of any major economy
they should be focused on setting that
right not on party political
considerations
um nice answer the question i actually
asked though was
about whether or not why it was that
labour used to think that higher
corporation tax was a good thing and now
you don't
well with respect i just said that we
would welcome
that longer time debate around
corporation tax i just said
that it has been concerning to see how
the consensus party
has pulled us away from the mainstream
on corporation tax but
why are they focused on this now why are
they focused on
increasing council tax directly for
families right now they're focused on it
because the chancellor has said to his
mps
that he wants to get tax changes out of
the way now
so they can have a clear run through to
the next general election
instead they should be focused on
promoting our economy
securing that recovery yes let's have
that long time discussion about tax
particularly to protect our high street
businesses but let's not pretend that
the conservative party is doing this
right now
because they want to secure our recovery
it seems to be driven by party political
considerations
so if rishi cena does propose higher
corporation tax labor's going to support
that vote and favor over it
if we see a long-term plan for getting
our country to a better place
on corporation tax particularly one
which faces up to that enormous gulf and
taxation for businesses based in brics
compared to
businesses based on the internet of
course we will look carefully at that
but what we don't want to see right now
is what the chancellor
is doing particularly in relation to
council tax the imposition of additional
costs
right now at a point when our country is
experiencing the worst
economic crisis of any major economy
so if there's a long-term plan for
corporation tax you'll look carefully at
that
does that mean you'll vote in favor of
higher corporation tax
well we need to look at how this would
be rolled out we need to make sure that
it would be a plan
that would actually make sense for
british business we've got to be doing
all we can to protect jobs and
businesses
right now but as i mentioned before one
of the really big problems with the uk
tax system is that big gulf
between how businesses based on our high
streets are taxed and their business
rates
are a huge problem the chancellor is
kicking the can down the road around
business rates reform now it's not going
to happen
apparently until the autumn that big
gulf between those businesses
and businesses that are largely based on
the internet where corporation tax
is more relevant of course not just the
rate of corporation tax but those
enormous loopholes
that the conservatives have allowed to
develop over the last 10 years
so we would look at any plan very
carefully but we're saying
very directly to the chancellor now
please don't be following
party politics for this budget follow
what is in the interest of our country
and its economic recovery
you mentioned now about the high streets
and the gulf between
online retailers and high street
retailers during the pandemic
does that mean you would support any
taxes aimed at online companies
well we've seen a lot of kite flying
from the government around this
issue and we haven't seen yet any
concrete proposals their digital
services tax really isn't the kind of
robust
change that we need to see to level that
playing field
so we would look at any proposals very
carefully but it's so
important that they do start to level
that playing field we've got businesses
really suffering on the high street
the government's planning changes are
actually going to make that worse i was
astonished to hear
the chancellor say that they would
improve the situation they could lead to
a wholesale
sell-off of our high streets so we
really do need to be getting this right
for the future
um your predecessor john mcdonnell uh
today that told the show last week
he'd like to see a windfall tax on
companies who have profited
um in the from the pandemic banks
property developers
tech companies would you support winfor
tax
well actually i'm sorry to sound like a
stuck record but
i believe what the government should be
focused on doing
right now is on protecting jobs and
businesses
of course there can and should be a
discussion into the future about the
nature of taxation but you know we have
suffered
the worst economic crisis of any major
economy in the uk and we're unique in
another way that we're the only country
that right now has a debate focused on
increasing
tax particularly on families that's the
wrong thing to be doing
right now absolutely let's have that
discussion for the future about taxation
but
right now let's please have a budget
that's focused on jobs
and businesses um you talk a lot about
your debate and discussion
in the future i'm just trying to get a
sense of what you
would do right now are there any tax
risers in this budget that you would
support
well with respect what i would be doing
right now if i were
chancellor is being focused on securing
the recovery what he should have done in
fact not right now but many many
tax rises it should have been clear
about that
sorry he should have been clear about
the continuation
of business rates about the continuation
of the vat reduction he should have
a clear roadmap for the future of wage
support and reform
that system because you know we can have
the chancellor
talking about how he would tax different
forms of economic activity
but if the tax base is shrinking as it
is right now
then that discussion is really a one
remove
from securing our recovery that is what
he should be focused on
um so you seem to be saying that right
now should be focused on on
on spending on supporting and people
during the pandemic are you worried at
all about the state of the public
finances so
clearly the chancellor has got his eye
on that are you worried about debt
levels
well of course they're a concern right
now we do have
very low interest rates but it's not
necessarily the case that that would
continue
forever so we do need to have a sensible
approach to this but
you know we've got to focus on that size
of the tax base you know
how many people are in work how many
businesses are operating
right now we've seen that tax base
shrinking we've seen record
redundancies and so it's really
important that we build that economic
activity back up that's what's happening
in other countries
and really the uk is well out of the
mainstream now
with the chancellor's approach so you
don't seem to support tax rises
you also seem to want more spending and
you're worried about the public finances
it sounds a bit like cake and eat it
boris johnson well no that's that's not
right because we want to see a much more
targeted approach first of all
we've seen billions of pounds wasted by
the government during this crisis the
chancellor
at no point has said that he would crack
down on that waste
so it's really important that we do
tackle it but secondly
we also need to see a much more targeted
approach from government if you look at
the business rates holiday for example
in england that's been provided to every
retailer including the very biggest
essential retailers that's been giving
them support that many
simply did not need in labor-run wales
they've had a much more targeted
approach that's ensured that actually
support has got
to where it's needed so let's talk about
having a targeted approach
let's stamp out that waste and
mismanagement and if we did that then
this crisis wouldn't be proving
as costly as it is under the
conservatives
okay just finally asked rishi sunak at
the end of the interview about shimon
begum the batman green school girl who
of course
left the uk to join islamic state um
do you think it's right that she hasn't
been allowed back to the uk to contest
that decision to strip her
of her british citizenship
well we've had that supreme court
judgment of course it was a complicated
judgment but we respect that judgment we
respect the rule of law